[Music]
every competition has a sound a cadence
and Tambor that reaches down to the
screen and brings it to life before your
eyes the enchanting tones of the
characters the familiar clash of the
battles and of course the voices that
carry it to you after all they're the
sound of the spirits and there are few
more memorable than Monte Cristo and
Doha no faker may be in trouble your
death Bart tries to clean it up for you
oh look at the class look at the boat
thank you well I was that the qss bullet
space United around the world's best and
most competitive league of Legends
region they redefine the way fans digest
eSports who's gonna go down it paved
their own way and brought their
personality to their casts in a way that
was lacking in the scene WTF 2 shens 2
shens this is the story of a segment of
the voice of the League of Legends and
later blizzards overwash League of
standing up for your peers and
trailblazing your craft
this is the story of Monti and Noah
Christopher Montecristo Mickle's
and Eric dill along Quist been in South
Korea back in 2012
Dola had moved to Korea to work for OGN
as a Starcraft and League of Legends
caster and was tasked with finding an
analyst to work with in the burgeoning
league scene I was working in a gym at
the time it was more familiar with the
League of Legends scene and kind of came
up with a list of people and kind of you
know gave me the breakdown on all of
them and you know mati came up and and
he threw the words he used were like
this guy is very professional but he's
also kind of mean and but he's also you
know very mature and all that and and I
was like that sounds you know that
sounds great actually I'd like to work
with someone you know who's got a bit
more maturity about them from there the
duo jumped into the vastly expanding
League of Legends ecosystem together
they were tasked with casting og ends
the champions in Korea which later
became known as the lck welcome Oh jam
champion spring I am Dora with me as
always is Monte Cristo we have day three
to this right we're already finishing
our first week of Champions break it's
insane Doha was relatively new to the
game so he relied on his previous
play-by-play experience while Monty
focused on the technical side of the
cast welcome back to the MLG fall
championship it's championship Sunday
and we have a championship-caliber
replay for you on this nós pro
performance analysis it was then when
the world's greatest League of Legends
scene was still in its infancy that the
duo cut their teeth
and gee that was the talking maneuver
what said 'give I know Jeff in its early
days eSports casting was very similar to
that of traditional sports off the play
action
but what was so unique about Monty and
Doha in the early years was the extent
to which they pushed against the status
quo he really understands the pacing of
a broadcast when to dial things back
when to change the focus of the
broadcasts off of eSports and that
sounds really strange but you our
audience doesn't want us to focus purely
on the game it didn't take much time for
the Korean scene to grow and attract a
lot of eyes but that didn't mean the
viewer experience was going to be
entertaining the kind of plotting
surgical style that Korean players are
known for doesn't exactly jump off the
screen and that's where this dynamic duo
jumped in they did with the Lannisters
send their regards Monty and Doha
quickly garnered a reputation for their
off-topic banter the way they let
viewers in and show their off-camera
personalities while in the booth what
the sugar in the hot chocolate I think
it's a malar put the mallow the hot
chocolate whatever put the lotion of the
basket I don't know when something is up
in this number of likes or late to speed
yeah absolutely
have you ever seen like one of those
centipedes move man they're terrifying
that's why Odin his horse eight-legged
horse was so fast right are you
referring to sleep there's this light
there yes yes see the league meta has
often been at its lowest in Korea on
average Korean teams opted for a slow
and steady risk-averse play style and
something had to fill that downtime
that's where what we now know as a Monti
and Dole cast was created that's right
it's almost like they read our minds and
they're like what would you like to see
in high definition of clothes I'd like
to see a pro gamer
are these the hands that will smite see
changes and that was why the community
fell in love with Monty and Doha we felt
like we got to know them better with
each passing broadcast they taught us
about support'll combat it's gonna be an
a support
he takes it he should not have got in
the way introduced us to the rain bros
remember that one season where we fixed
rainbow suits yeah you know I'm really
glad you wore that out the other night
you know when we went and hit the club's
that was a great choice I thought yeah
that was awesome and reminded us of
Goa's hatred for Nami singing oh wow get
the full channels yeah they know they
know I hate it and lissandra's voice
lines I don't know why in the green
client they made lissandra have to like
make some noise with a noise like she's
choking to death every time Fionna and
it was that willingness to break the
fourth wall and let the viewers into
their world that led to their increasing
celebrity but a lot of it's just our
personality you know it's just kind of
the way we act on the cast outside the
cast's kind of who we are and League of
Legends had that downtime kind of that
gave you a little bit more time to to
bring that out and of course there was
that one line during the 2013 Korean
summer finals that kinda broke the
internet the Katy bullets bass with one
line Doha cemented his place among
esports royalty was just you know my
mind was blown I kind of just lost it
you know and it was just kind of a
culmination of all the excitement
bolt-in inside the game and outside the
game that encapsulated that entire sort
of sort of day it was it was a pretty
pretty unforgettable experience is for
sure another one of the catalysts for
Monty and doors rise came later that
year during the broadcast of the 2013
World Championship
who will win the season 3 World
Championship SK Telecom t1 or Royal Club
well I want my BIC g1 for the
championship hands down I've got my
tickets here I've got tickets to the
Korean hype train and I will be giving
him out it's your last chance
first-class still available crap oh here
let me go ahead I'll go ahead and punch
this for you there you go as SK Telecom
t1 and faker swept Royal Club 3 Oh in
front of a sold-out Staples Center Korea
became league's most important region
overnight if 2013 was the year that
Korea made its mark on the international
scene then 2014 marked the beginning of
the region's dominance hey guys welcome
to champions summer I'm doing that spot
eager so today our final semi-final
match it's a Samsung face-off it is time
I think it's gonna be really fun man
because today we have not only the best
team conceivably Korea and maybe the
world but also the second team in Korea
and maybe the world but 2014 also
featured one of the most competitive and
beloved domestic finals in Korean
history
[Music]
I couldn't help it I think we actually
just witnessed the grand finals of
twitch chat but now it's a pile of
League of Legends that's right Katie
arrows versus this five-game set will go
down in Korean League of Legends history
and of course it was Monte and Doha who
tracked the sounds that fans will never
forget
at that year's World Championship
Samsung fielded to star-studded lineups
and Korea would go on to defend their
world's title the same accessory folks
they're gonna focus in pop the neck to
the south
well
as 2014 came to an end many of Korea's
brightest stars were drawn away from the
region in favor of larger contracts
elsewhere dubbed the great Korean Exodus
Monte and dole foundation
basically the two best teams in the
league every single star player that was
a fan favorite that was amazing in 2014
was now gone and what that ended up
meaning was a continuation of their love
affair with the greatest league of
legends team of all time SK Telecom t1
[Applause]
as you might imagine this kind of
once-in-a-lifetime team pairs pretty
well with a casting duo as beloved as
Monty in Doha hello and welcome to the
League of Legends World Championship
Korea regionals I'm send with me as shen
and today we see if wait WTF 2 shens 2 1
2 shens and this was particularly true
in 2015 where the league of legends
metagame was slogged down by the late
game focused cinderhulk meta it was
common for games in the cinderhulk meta
to go on for what seemed like forever
and it allowed the duo in addition to SK
Telecom's resurgence Korea was blessed
with yet another great team in 2015 the
lineup that made up the GE Tigers in the
spring split and the Koo Tigers during
summer I've never seen a team that is
louder
in the Koo Tigers a team of misfits the
Tigers rose from relative obscurity to
challenge SKT and even finished above
them in the standings
during the lck spring regular season but
2015 was still the year of SKT monte and
OA followed them to Worlds that year and
that would be the only time they'd go
together why does anybody want to kill
each other this is a land of plenty no
kids there's a little bit there's buddy
there's infinite Baron and dragon meet
you got clean water here in the river
there's it there's an endless supply of
gold and shops to buy things out why
fight it all this seems like a paradise
I mean get rid of all these champions
man I just want to move in and live yeah
I feel like for easyhoon getting crazy
is like letting the four pencils in a
perfect line on his desk be a little bit
out of alignment I feel like well it's a
crazy day guys on the rift and in the
booth the story of 2016 for Monty and
Doha was the continued dominance of SK
Telecom and the rise of the Rox Tigers
as a legitimate contender to faker's
throne this group of players that have
either retired or been rejected by a
big sponsor no big team house it's not
necessary because they are going to lck
summer and they are going to get a
spotted world's again there it is brunch
Tigers taken Gigi it's about time they
finally over
is bears now it's not just their
reputation that has historically
separated Monte and Ella from the rest
of League of Legends broadcast talent
unlike other casters who are employed by
Riot Games Monte and Doha freelanced for
OGN and it's something that both casters
have been increasingly outspoken about
over the years it has been difficult for
us to predict or have a lot of trust in
what Ryan's going to do especially in
regards to us as as you know non riah
casters there's been very little
stability for freelancers in the scene
the importance of autonomy and agency
was never lost on them this has at times
landed them at the center of controversy
especially when the casting community
needed someone to take a stand for them
in 2016 and right now riot is doing a
very poor job of keeping up with the
market in terms of their own casters
they always have you know if we accepted
these kinds of rates and they had kind
of gone down from what they hadn't even
done the previous years they were saying
that like Casas Romer hey know that we
just felt that that was a dangerous
precedent that we didn't want set for
the industry in general the two casters
in conjunction with their colleague Papa
smithy penned an open letter to Riot
Games refusing to work for them at the
midseason Invitational in protest of the
compensation that they were providing
for their casters you know yeah we were
giving up you know a chunk of money
ourselves by writing this letter and by
you know kind of taking the stand
whenever anybody isn't going to be in
this situation because we're all
basically going to be in this situation
that I found myself in right now 2016
will always be about where they weren't
after World Championship people wanted
Monti and Doha right I'm sure people
here would love to see them great cost
is in their own right that's right I set
the name Chad please everyone knows that
table their humor at that great
broadcasters for all the funny moments
and booming calls their single greatest
contribution to their trade was setting
the mold
they made themselves irreplaceable and
fought to define casting in a growing
eSports scene I think a South Korea sent
the wrong person to the Olympics know
that part of the Lord makes sense yes
all right well guys thanks for watching
today's his popularity continued to grow
Monti specifically was not without his
fair share of controversy having
previously served as clg's head coach
Monti was a big voice within league of
legends and of course one of the
community's most prominent critics of
riot games for years fact that riot
casters are sort of caged in by riot
where they can't produce their own
content they well they can't monetize it
on their youtubes or their twitch they
do not get paid by independent events
that they cast at such as Intel Extreme
Masters IEM and that their salaries are
in fact pretty low when you think about
the size of League of Legends in and of
that it is the largest eSport in the
english-speaking world ahead of the 2016
na LCS season monty became the outright
owner of renegades
0:16 sounds like our team's future
record against the Koreans
hi I'm Monte Cristo what do I do for
renegades I look good for the cameras
and that doesn't change whether we win
or we lose the team previously known as
misfits was an upstart Challenger squad
that had been owned by Chris Badawi that
is until Badawi was forced to step down
from the team after riot ruled that he
had been trying to persuade contracted
players to join the roster previously
Chris Baddeley was the one who had did
have ownership in the team as soon as we
got into the LC
we transferred the seed to being wholly
owned by a company that was wholly owned
by me
renegades would go on to have a
disappointing five and thirteen spring
split in 2016 before receiving even more
bad news
riot had filed a competitive ruling
against the team that stated the team
knowingly violated the competitive ban
against Chris Badawi the ruling claimed
that Monti had committed to hand back
part of renegades to Badawi once his
suspension was lifted which according to
riot is grounds for violation battery is
banned for the remainder of the 2015 and
the entirety of the 2016 season so he
cannot be a coach owner or manager of
the team in the official riot capacity
when it says manager he could be the CEO
of the company he can manage the whole
team on-site he cannot be an officially
named manager for the team visiting the
LCS these allegations arose following
the trade of RF legendary flares and
Alex each from renegades to team dragon
Knights in exchange for serif and ninja
that said Monti explicitly explained the
reasoning for the trade in a video
following the incident and provides a
thorough paper trail of his
communications with riot games during
the renegades investigation if I was
promising which I did not chrisbattery a
50% ownership stake in my company that I
wholly owned it would still be subject
to riots approval for him to game an
ownership stake in my company therefore
I cannot have promised it to him because
it was conditional on riots approval in
the first place
renegades were then forced to disband
and lost their LCS slot and the ongoing
feud between Monti and Riot Games hit
its climax but I don't have a team to
lose any more I don't have a formal
relationship with the LCS to lose which
is why some of these rulings current
team owners can't speak up about them
in retrospect one of the biggest
benefits Monti and Ola got out of
maintaining their freelancer status was
being able to cast other games once you
get sort of the process down for what
you need to do personally as a caster to
get ready to cast a game you know at
this point I feel like I could cast
anything you know at the proper amount
of time on May 24th 2016 Blizzard
released overwatch a Class B shooter
that looked primed to enter the eSports
world shortly after launch the gaming
world took notice Monti and Doha
included an elite international task
force charged with ending the war and
restoring Liberty to all nations
overwatch when negotiating their
freelancing contracts with OGN in 2017
the duo had casting overwatch written
into their contracts due to their high
hopes for the game's competitive scene
this led to them getting to cast one of
overwatch is first big E sports leagues
apex in Korea with Monte Cristo here we
go man it's a new game it's overwatch
it's gonna be epic
that's right it's our third big game
together don't write legalized in
Starcraft 2 now overwatch that we're
casting together they christened this
new game by once again being the
soundtrack to a trailblazing final
series a casters dream
roadog man oh there's a whole shoe ohon
and no soldier 76 means this is over man
Jin catch and out kills and that is a
tournament envious should have no
trouble at all pushing the payload
Mantha picks into the team fight win and
that is it envious will win an Intel
overwatch a pic season one with a 4'o
victory and as we now know they were
right overwatch is huge and after
Blizzard announced the overwatch League
we all knew the game's eSports future
was only getting brighter montina had a
lot of time to prepare for overwatch so
it was just a lot of practice cast with
each other talking with each other
watching games with each other to get
ready for it and you know we've still
got some work to do obviously because
we're pretty new at casting overwatch
but I think it's been pretty good so far
and then Monty and Doha shocked the
eSports world on April 14 2017 they
announced they'd be stepping away from
League of Legends entirely moving from
Korea to LA to cast the overwatch league
yeah it's been really great obviously to
cast ten seasons now of league of
legends here in korea and we started
this before LCS even existed so it's
been an honor to be able to cast the
scene that has been the most dominant
the highest level league we both have a
great love for the game and we're pretty
sad to leave it behind it certainly
wasn't an easy decision with a few
parting words and a couple glasses of
scotch they were gone
the overwatch League was a huge
commercial success in year one they
attracted massive financial groups to
buy teams big-name sponsors for the
league and their production quality was
some of the best we've ever seen from
eSports rolling early joannec does go
down a res comes in from NY excel and
here comes fine gets one gets two
looking for a bit more it gets another
one are you kidding me this guy is gonna
single-handedly change the point back
over okay hi boss blind is on the scene
the game has its challenges and both
Milan T and Dawa respectively have
remarked that it's the hardest game
they've ever had to cast it's it's
hugely different it's vastly different
its first along it's a hardest game ever
casted for sure and you've got I think
the big difference is that you've got
much more limited vision on what's
happening in the game than you do in
like a Starcraft or League of Legends or
a hearthstone it is the most difficult
game i have ever cast i actually think
it is one of if not the most difficult
games that has ever existed to cast and
there are spectating issues but their
signature style has lived on they've
made the jump to a brand new game
consulted for a brand new league and
made it out
mostly unscathed now robot is doing the
robot I mean we expect round that's what
happens build your backs and happen do
dances in the middle of your Russian
city Wow what a tremendous waste of fuel
but hey maybe there's solar powered in
the future who knows it's alright we
have bigger waste of fuel in the
overwatch league done early on some fans
of overwatch were critical of their
banter and wanted more hype out of
League of Legends as most sarcastic duo
but as times gone on they've managed to
adapt to this new world and even found
different broadcast avenues for their
wit to shine through what's up overwatch
fans it's mad Monty and the Dola taking
you through your morning drive uber will
be here in just a bit with his tank
traffic on the tens but we're going to
talk some overwatch League in the
meantime Doha how are you feeling as we
head into week 5 of stage 2 that's great
I feel that way too doll gonna be seated
ok let's see what type of overwatch
hoodlums we're dealing with today
they didn't just succeed they paved the
way for their peers to do the same to
make casting eSports a real career you
know at the end of the day you know if
you really want these parts to grow you
gotta have those moments where you have
to stand up for yourself and for the
industry and and kind of accepted you
know whatever happens from that and
Monti and Doha more or less force their
career to work and well it did it's been
five years of my life living in South
Korea and I loved it but today you know
what I'm gonna be
[Applause]
you did not expect this at all you know
people have been wanting me to cheer for
America for years to protect the
American you know I called it boy
today's not that day No
[Applause]
Turia baby you know you want to learn
let's do a Korean lesson with door right
now the verb is the rope duh that's
Korean for lonely I've got our strategy
spinner here and it includes such CLG
classics as win one game to give the
fans false hope here's a real reason why
we all love these words because the way
we love watching people fight each other
in video games that's what it's all
about that's why it's fun that's how I'm
gonna end things see you next time
thanks for watching thank you so much
for sticking with us and we hope you
will in the future seriously
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]